hopefully this turns out better than the
frankenstein monster chris has put
together one unit at a time his perfect
team
uh
i kind of like it i'm not gonna lie
i i i i i'd like to come up with a way
to knock it but uh chris that's pretty
well done um well
thanks
i i will say this though i understand
that the saints have great depth at
quarterback and i'm very partial to
taysom hill
i'd have to go with the chiefs
quarterbacks over the saints why did you
go with new orleans
well we we did it i tried to stay within
the spirit of the exercise right we're
doing team building as in like hey you
want to have a team and have great depth
and everything like that and you know
again i think if patrick mahomes gets
hurt
in kansas city i i don't feel great
about listen i like chad henny but i
would certainly feel more comfortable
with having oh taysom hill and jameis
winston at my disposal so it was more
about building the perfect team as far
as depth and having some cya right cover
your own
butt okay as they'll say there because
well hey of course i think
listen whoa why would you out of
yourself and not say ass
i don't know you're right the guy who
the guy who drops an s bomb a couple of
weeks ago is now is now like ultra
careful you're tiptoeing through the
minefield go ahead
well i i you know let me go ahead and
curse i mean go ahead and get into your
point
yeah well the s bomb got me s scared
okay so i'm afraid to say it again all
right
but but yeah i mean that's what we're
trying to do here you know specifically
like with with the running back position
of course christian mccaffrey is the guy
you look at and go oh that would be a
great guy to have on my team for the
perfect all 22 team
but
i mean if christian mccaffrey gets hurt
who's your backup tell me somebody out
there tell me who the backup running
back is and the carolina panthers oh
yeah nobody would know it's mike davis
right now so yeah with the baltimore
ravens because they have four guys that
are unbelievable you got like two speed
fast guys you got a starter and a backup
you got like a jk dobbins and hill and
then you got two power guys and and mark
ingram and august edwards so to me
that's what we're doing here it's about
the building of a team and you know like
the great teams if you have one injury
it doesn't ruin your team you have other
people to come in and go okay we can
still execute our game plan of what we
do because we're not ruined by that one
guy being off the field
i'll agree with you at running back i'd
rather have those guys than a group led
by arguably the best running back in
football because
injuries much more likely at the running
right position quarterback i'm not gonna
go run and hide over the possibility
pack my home's getting injured because i
want patrick mahomes when he's healthy
and there's a lower risk of him getting
injured than a running back and last
year chad henny wasn't healthy either
and it was matt moore that came in and
saved their bacon by doing just enough
to allow them to have the number two
seed not the number three seed in the
afc when the playoffs rolled around and
uh so yeah i'd still i you know i get
you forget i forget you did all
all right but now let's assume that it's
accurate we'll accept for the purposes
of this exercise your list
based upon the units you've selected
would you rather have
that colts offensive line and that wall
that has been built in indianapolis a
few hundred miles north
or the chief's receivers
which would you rather have
well
you know i think i'd rather have the
colts offensive line you know the chiefs
receivers i love them you know that but
you know part of their specialness is
that guy that can throw bombs to them
off his back foot and do all of those
things not all quarterbacks could take
advantage of the true strengths of those
chiefs wide receivers all the times you
know if you're just really building a
team and you didn't know who your
quarterback was to have the dominant
offensive line gives you more
flexibility and can save your whatever
quarterback you had back there so yeah i
guess i'd go with the colts line you'd
feel the same way
yeah absolutely and when you put it in
the context of putting the colts
offensive line in kansas city if you
give patrick mahomes even more time he's
eventually going to find someone who is
open enough for him to deliver one of
those lasers that you'd like to throw
give me the sound effect one of those
lasers is gonna fire
yes
he's dangerous enough when the when the
protection breaks down how much how much
harder would it be to defend the chiefs
if he actually had the kind of
protection not not that he has bad
protection but if you give him a great
offensive line my goodness he would be
even better all right would you rather
have the 49ers defensive line or the
patriots defensive backs chris
whoa this is this is really a tough one
here you know again i think i'm going to
favor the line play
more than anything you know i think they
can affect the game in more areas you
know first off hey the 49ers had the
number one pass defense in football last
year right and it's one of the best pass
defenses we saw in football over the
last 10 years
so
within that and we don't none of us look
at that san francisco secondary and go
oh that's one of the five best
secondaries in football oh my gosh they
have some shut down corners no they were
the top past events in football because
hey they were good in the secondary but
they were great at the defensive line so
as much as i have respect for that
patriot secondary and all that if you
don't have a creative coach to confuse
some things up in the front seven and
create some pressure on a quarterback
you know those dbs you can only cover
for so long i don't care if you got four
dion sanders out there if the
quarterback's sitting there all day four
or five seconds to throw it's going to
be hard for them to cover everybody like
that so i'm going to go with the 49ers
d-line
i'm always taking a defensive line over
a defensive backfield chris if you've
got a dominant defensive line you and i
could play defensive back because the
quarterback is never going to have time
to even find a guy remotely open he's
running for his life more than anything
else and once you hit him a few times
that becomes his main focus i mean what
has ultimately taken down the patriots
at their best it wasn't a great
defensive backfield it was a great
defensive line that gets pressure on the
quarterback early and often and begins
to inflict physical harm not harm but
you know the whole idea is you hit him
and you make him think
right i have to worry about this now
right if if if the defensive backs are
covering your receivers it doesn't
inflict physical pain upon you getting
hit by that line does and it gets in
your head and it gets you thinking too
much about those guys who are chasing
you so yes absolutely all right um would
you rather have the buccaneers tight
ends or the ravens running backs chris
oh this one yeah that's it it is a tough
one there's three good tight ends down
there in tampa that i'm excited about um
i i think i i um man
i think i'd rather have the running
backs though i do you know especially
right now in 2020 you know with the
running backs being able to do so much
more almost all of them can come in the
nfl and catch the ball
seamlessly out of the backfield they can
run routes like slot receivers a lot of
them and those ravens running backs i
mean that's they're truly
game breakers that way like hey listen i
like cameron breit and oj howard and we
know gronk but he's been out of football
for a year jk doblins can go around the
edge for 80 yard touchdowns mark ingram
can get more eight and 10 yard tough
runs up the middle than just about any
running back in football you know so i
look at that and then let alone there's
two good guys behind them on each side
you know each side there that are that
are pretty impressive too so i go ravens
running backs here
yeah i agree with you too i think the
the running back position is a greater
piece of the overall offense it has more
impact running the ball and catching the
ball the tight ends ultimately are just
a piece of the passing game even though
they are great tight ends in tampa bay i
agree with you i'd rather have a better
complement of running backs than tight
ends all right this last one
would you rather have chris's ideal team
or chris's ideal coaching staff
head coach bill belichick offensive
coordinator kyle shanahan defensive
coordinator wink martindale chris i must
have missed the day that kyle shanahan
got fired by the 49ers and hired by
someone else as an offensive coordinator
what the hell is this
well you know i just figured if we're
going to build the perfect team i need
to build the perfect coaching staff and
that's the one i like the most you know
i i think as much as uh
my my buddy kyle
shanahan and i you know have a good
relationship i think he would realize
he'd have to be relegated to a
coordinator position if bill belichick
was there you know as awesome as he is
right now so yeah i thought that to me
kyle's the best offensive mind in the
game right now i think don wink
martindale is the best defensive mind of
the game and of course belichick might
be the best of all of them and put them
all together and being the head coach
and all that the real question is here
so what so wait a minute so what would
you do so what are you taking are you
taking your team or you're taking this
coaching staff well that the here's the
question to me like all right first off
do do we have any say on who's coaching
the team itself i mean that's the point
if we're gonna do this crazy we're gonna
demote guys from head coaches into
coordinator jobs yeah this one's easy
for me i i i'm taking the team and i'm
gonna go out and take a i'll take sean
payton to make him the offensive
coordinator i'll make mike zimmer the
defensive coordinator and i'll be the
head coach
how hard can that be
i don't i don't think zimmer or sean
payton would listen to you one time that
sort of would be fun they'd be like what
head coach shut the hell up i'll call it
i won you don't know anything i'd like
to see that i'll say i'll go sit down
and say i'm just going to watch the game
you guys go to work
i'm with you though i think i'd take the
players too as long as you're not like
throwing like johnny high school coach
to coach the players yes uh that's too
much talent on the football team even
for great coaches like belichick and
shanahan and martindale to overcome
i hear all the time that on game day the
head coach really doesn't have much to
do and that it's just when do you go for
it on fourth down when do you call your
timeouts right you the big picture
decisions i could do that if i knew that
i had a great offensive coordinator a
great defensive coordinator i could
figure out when to go for it on fourth
down i can figure out when to call a
timeout i play madden every day
oh that's right you played madden that's
right you're ready to be a head coach
hey and you would be you would be the
king of like we're gonna go up seven and
you're gonna go for two to go up nine
aren't you that's the other thing
absolutely
absolutely baby making a two-story game
on side kicks onside kick school if
you're doing hey if you learn by madden
you always go for it on fourth down
onside kicks fake pants yeah it would be
it it i may not be very successful but
the games would definitely be
entertaining
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports